[Music]
the popular used crime comedy knives out
was released in september 2019 and
convinced fans and critics alike
in line with netflix announcement that
they are planning two sequels their
first newcomers were also introduced a
few days ago
we can already tell you one thing marvel
fans will definitely get their money's
worth
one of them is still in the current
squad of the mcu and is no other than
dave bautista but the 52 year old drax
actor is not the only
top class edition for knife sound 2 as
fight club and x-hulk actor
edward norton is also part of the team
naturally the cast also includes a few
familiar faces which is why daniel crack
will once again be playing master
detective benoit blanc
whether other stars who appeared in the
original will be back is not yet clear
but in view of the new storyline and
appearance by jamie lee curtis anna
armas or chris evans is rather unlikely
instead we can look forward to an
entirely unexpected
appearance because rumors have recently
begun to circulate about the casting of
jeannette monet
judging by the hollywood reporter the 35
year old is in the midst of talks and
will take on a role that is still
unknown hopefully director ryan johnson
will be able to create a similarly
fantastic production behind the camera
as he did with the previous film after
all filming is scheduled to begin this
summer in greece
a release date for knife sound 2 as well
as for knife saw 3
is still pending the production of the
new scorsese project killers of the
flower moon is making progress
the first image of the upcoming thriller
which stars leonardo dicaprio alongside
the legendary director
was published a few days ago and shows
the shutter island star alongside fellow
actress
lily gladstone in terms of content the
movie is based on the bestseller
killers of the flower moon the osage
murders and the birth of the fbi by book
author david graham
it tells the story of a real live series
of murders in 1920s oklahoma involving a
big oil company with no scruples in the
fight for
large oil reserves in the end the
company stops at nothing and goes so far
as to dislodge native americans from
their historic homes
of course dicaprio is not the only actor
who has experience working in movies
directed by martin scorsese
in fact another leading role will be
given to movie star robert de niro
incidentally the project will be
released not only in theaters but also
exclusively on apple tv plus and it cost
a whopping 150 to
200 million us dollars to make right now
it's not clear when a release can be
expected but it seems
likely that the release date will be
sometime in 2022
there hasn't been any relevant info on
the upcoming jurassic world dominion for
quite some time now
many fans are pleased to hear that this
is now over as empire recently published
a snapshot of the upcoming dinosaur
blockbuster
honor you can see not only chris pratt
as own grady but also supporting actor
omasa
in his role as barry at present the
frenchman is very high on the list in
large part to the very successful
netflix series lupone and after a break
in the second jurassic world
he now celebrates his return there is
unfortunately not a lot more to see in
the picture they do seem to be
consulting with director colin trevor
and are in some kind of bunker or
cave however omission chris pratt aren't
the only returnees as sam neil loradon
and of course jeff goldblum also make an
appearance
the three jurassic park veterans will
ensure that jurassic park and jurassic
world
merge so after a long and in part
difficult production due to the pandemic
in about a year it'll be finally time
for you to watch
jurassic world dominion in theaters
starting june 10
2022 things are heating up in the
mission impossible franchise
lead actor tom cruise recently commented
on a clip from the shooting of the
seventh part that has been circulating
on the web for months
the talk is about really daring
motorcycle stunt that took place during
the movie shooting in norway
tom cruise himself is seen riding off a
long ramp into the abyss
opening his parachute at the last moment
after
many extraordinary stunts by the 50 year
old and new climax seems to have been
reached in the most
literal sense of the word speaking in an
interview with empire he himself sees it
the same way and sums up that a single
puff of wind would have been enough to
knock him
off balance in addition he had to be
careful not to get entangled on the
motorcycle as
otherwise he would have fallen with a
motorcycle into the depth
considering that the actor is already
celebrating his 60th birthday next year
the performance is
all the more amazing another sneak peek
is provided by a picture that shows the
actor standing nonchalantly on a moving
train
you can find out what the whole film
will look like when it's released on may
27
2022 no one was expecting this
dave bautista will move on from his
popular role as drax after the upcoming
guardians of the galaxy vol 3. the u.s
actor announced this in the course of a
promotional interview for his upcoming
movie
army of the dead and has a very
reasonable explanation for his decision
on the one hand his contract with marvel
ants after guardians of the galaxy iii
on the other hand he wished that more
would have been made of his character he
does have a point after all rex brings
an interesting character and background
story that marvel
in his opinion had completely forgotten
about however he himself expressly
emphasized that this is not an attack on
marvel given that marvel has its own
plans for the mcu director james gunn
was the first to express his regret
making it clear that there could be no
other drax than bodista even though he
accepted the actor's decision
in order to prevent misunderstandings
bautista also let the fans know that the
character
drax will of course live on in the mcu
but merely without him as a cast member
especially interesting in this regard is
a statement by james gunn regarding a
fourth part in fact it is supposed to
end after part three
though on twitter gun didn't really give
a clear no
and asked whether he would direct part
4. thus part 4 shouldn't be completely
ruled out although the signs are more in
favor of an end after part 3.
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 is
expected to be released at the beginning
of may 2023
in 2014 the popular u.s blockbuster edge
of tomorrow starring tom cruise and
emily blunt hit theaters
in an interview with howard stern blonde
spoke out about a potential follow-up
unfortunately blonde doesn't seem to be
too upbeat she personally thinks that
edge of tomorrow 2 will be far too
expensive after the first part cost
almost 200 million us dollars to produce
this is not an unjustified objection
despite the fact that tom cruise emily
blunt and director doug lyman have
frequently expressed their interest in
the sequel
i'm going to talk earlier this year
about wanting to make a sequel
substantially smaller than the original
and now we know why so it remains
unclear whether a cut down sequel with a
focus on the characters
will actually be realized paramount has
published
seven images from its plant series
adaption paw patrol
the popular franchise has been a
nickelodeon since 2013 and deals with
the live of young writer and his six
differently gifted four-legged
companions each of the ducks has a
specific position for example
one's a policeman the other firefighter
the paramount project has done a great
job with its voice actors including
jimmy kimmel tyler perry
reynold park and kim kardashian as part
of its cast apart from the dock chase
all the main actors from the series will
also be featured in terms of content the
well coordinated team faces the rival
mayor of adventure city and as he starts
to wreak havoc
ryder and his friends try to stop the
mayor with the help of new allies
based on the pictures you can at least
get a first impression of what's to come
and we're looking forward to more
details about the upcoming paw patrol
the movie and its release on august 20th
2021
the trailer should be released within
the next few days subscribe to our
channel to
not miss it
[Music]